♪ ♪
>> Tucker: LAST WEEK'S
SHOOTING IN PARKLAND, FLORIDA,
HAS SPARKED NEW DEMANDS FOR GUN
CONTROL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE COURSE, AMERICA'S GUN
OWNERSHIP RATE USED TO BE A LOT
HIGHER THAN IT IS TODAY.
DEADLY SCHOOL SHOOTINGS ARE
MOSTLY A RECENT PHENOMENON.
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
COULD IT BE OUR OVERALL CULTURE
HAS UNDERGONE A TOXIC SHIFT?
THEY SUGGESTED THAT VIOLENT
VIDEO GAMES AND TV SHOWS HAVE
CREATED "A DESENSITIZED
CULTURE."
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
THAT IS KIND OF THE QUESTION.
FEWER AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS OWNED
GUNS THEN 50 YEARS AGO WHEN WE
DIDN'T HAVE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE DIFFERENCE
IS BETWEEN THEN AND NOW?
>> I THINK WE HAD TO ASK
OURSELVES WHAT HAS CHANGED.
GUN OWNERSHIP ITSELF HAS NOT
CHANGED.
IF, IN FACT, THERE ARE MORE GUN
RESTRICTIONS NOW.
THERE ARE MORE RULES ABOUT WHO
CAN AND CAN'T OWN A GUN OR HOW A
GUN MIGHT BE ACQUIRED THEN THERE
WERE 50 AND 100 YEARS AGO.
AND YET, CHILDREN DID NOT
SLAUGHTER CHILDREN AT SCHOOL.
IT IS IN THE GUN.
SOMETHING CULTURAL HE HAS
CHANGED.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE HAVE
BECOME SIGNIFICANTLY
DESENSITIZED TO DEATH AND
VIOLENCE.
WE ARE TRAINING CHILDREN WHETHER
WE INTEND TO OR NOT, WHETHER
IT'S ANYONE'S DESIRE OR NOT, TO
VIDEO GAMES, TWO MOVIES, THROUGH
MUSICAL LYRICS, THROUGH
TELEVISION SHOWS,
INCREASINGLY DURING PRIME
TIME.
THE AMOUNT OF VIOLENCE IT IS
INCREASINGLY REALISTIC,
INCREASINGLY GRAPHIC.
THERE IS A COST TO THIS.
YOU COUPLE THAT WITH THE NUMBER
OF PSYCHIATRIC DRUGS THAT
CHILDREN AND ADULTS ARE ON.
THE NUMBER OF WARNINGS ABOUT
DEPRESSION AND SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS, YOU COUPLE ALL OF THAT
WITH THE FACT THAT OUR SOCIETY
HAS A SHIFTED TO THE DEGREE THAT
THEY ARE LARGELY NONEXISTENT.
WE KNOW LONGER HAVE THESE
DELINEATED BOUNDARIES.
THESE CHILDREN ARE INCREASINGLY
COMING FROM BROKEN HOMES AS
WELL.
THEY FIND THEMSELVES FATHERLESS.
YOU UNDERSTAND IT'S IMPORTANT
WHAT HAPPENS AT HOME HAS A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON WHAT YOUR
CHILDREN DO OUT THERE.
TOO MANY CHILDREN DON'T HAVE THE
BLESSING OF HAVING A STABLE
ENVIRONMENT AT HOME.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT HAS
CHANGED IN SOCIETY AND NOT HAVE
A KNEE-JERK RESPONSE THAT
ANOTHER RULE AND ANOTHER
REGULATION IS THE ANSWER.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING YOU'VE
SAID HAS MADE SENSE.
I DON'T KNOW THE SOCIAL SCIENCE
ON IT, BUT IT DOESN'T SOUND
CRAZY AT ALL.
IT SOUNDS OBVIOUS.
SOME OF QUICKLY WHY YOU YOU
THINK WHAT YOU JUST SAID GETS A
HOSTILE REACTION FROM SOME
PEOPLE.
WHY DO THEY HATE TO HEAR THAT?
>> IT DOES NOT FIT THE NARRATIVE
PEOPLE WANT.
FOR A THOUSAND REASONS, PEOPLE
HAVE A PRECONCEIVED NOTION THAT
ANOTHER GUN RESTRICTION, ANOTHER
RULE OR REGULATION OR
GOVERNMENTAL INTERVENTION OF
SOME SORT IS THE ANSWER.
WHEN IN FACT, NOBODY WANTS TO
LOOK AT WHAT THEY HAVE TO LOOK
AT IF IT'S NOT THAT.
THAT IS, WHAT OUR RESPONSIBILITY
IS IN SOCIETY AS INDIVIDUALS, AS
PARENTS, AS TEACHERS, AS
EDUCATORS, AS PEOPLE IN THE
CHURCHES AND CIVIC ORGANIZATIONS
AND YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS, WHAT
ARE WE NOT DOING THAT WAS DONE A
GENERATION AGO TO PROVIDE THE
TYPE OF GUIDANCE THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED AS THEY GROW UP?
HOW YOU DEAL WITH DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION?
I WILL TELL YOU ONE OTHER THING
I'VE NOT SAID BUT I'M SURE THIS
WILL MAKE PEOPLE'S HEADS
EXPLODE.
WE ARE -- SOME OF THE CHILDREN
THAT WE DO THIS.
NOT ANYONE'S ATTENTIONS, BUT WE
ARE MAKING HEROES OF A CHILD WHO
HAS NO BUSINESS TO HAVE THEIR
FACE PUT OUT THERE.
THE BALANCE, PSYCHOLOGICALLY AND
BALANCE WILL SAY WHY NOT?
I WILL GET MY 15 MINUTES OF
FAME.
IF WE DON'T THINK THERE IS A
COPYCAT MENTALITY, WE ARE NOT
PAYING ATTENTION.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE NATURE
OF THE INTERNET.
THAT WAS INTERESTING, THANK YOU.
DAVE GROSSMAN IS THE AUTHOR OF
ASSASSINATION GENERATION AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU JUST SAID YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN THE SOCIAL SCIENCE
ON IT YET.
HERE IT IS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHY I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU.
THIS IS THE KIND OF IDEA THAT
GETS IN THE MIST AS -- DISMISSED
BY PEOPLE WHO KNOW NOTHING.
>> THE RULING CLASS.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS A SOCIAL
SCIENCE?
>> SURGEON GENERAL AFTER SURGEON
GENERAL HAS MADE STATEMENTS
WHERE MATTERS CAME BEFORE THE
SUPREME COURT, CALIFORNIA LAW TO
REGULATE FILTERS ACCESS TO
VIDEO GAMES.
THE VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY HAS
FOUND 82 JOURNALISM -- 82 MEDIA
PROFESSORS THAT TOLD THE
SUPREME COURT THERE IS NO
SCIENTIFIC PROOF.
IT WAS ACADEMIC MALFEASANCE.
OUR ENTIRE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
SAID ONE OF THE DISSENTING
JUSTICES IN THE SUPREME COURT
THAT I'M NOT A MEDICAL EXPERT
BUT I KNOW WHO IS.
IS THE ENTIRE MEDICAL COMMUNITY,
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
SCHOLARS TELLING US.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T IMAGINE AS
ANYONE I'D RATHER LEFT TAKE
ADVICE FROM THIN JOURNALISM
PROFESSOR.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A DUMBER GROUP
OF PEOPLE.
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> THE MALFEASANCE OF JOURNALISM
PROFESSORS MAKE IT LOOK AS A
JOINT STATEMENT TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
HERE'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
LOOK AT THIS.
IT WAS 2002, AN IDENTICAL CRIME
HAPPENED IN GERMANY, 19-YEAR-OLD
HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUT MURDERED 17
PEOPLE IN SCHOOL.
IDENTICAL CRIME.
GERMANY 2002.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE GUNS.
GERMANY CAN'T STOP IT.
WE SAW THIS WEEKEND, A MASSACRE
IN MECCA CHURCH IN RUSSIA.
RUSSIA IS A TOTALITARIAN NATION.
THEY CAN'T STOP PEOPLE FROM
GETTING GUNS.
THE MOST HORRIFIC JUVENILE
MASSACRE IN HISTORY, A
17-YEAR-OLD KID IN 2009 IN
GERMANY MURDERED 15 PEOPLE.
GERMANY CAN'T STOP IT.
RUSSIA CAN'T STOP IT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT TAKING AWAY GUNS.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE THE MEDIA
SO HESITANT TO GO AFTER THE BIG
BUSINESSES THAT ARE PROFITING
FROM THIS GARBAGE?
THAT'S A QUESTION I'D LIKE TO
EXPLORE.
>> IT'S THEIR DONOR BASE AND
THEIR VOTER BASE.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY'VE LOST THE
GUN OWNERS.
THEY KNOW THEY FOSSILS BOTH.
TO ATTACK THE GUN OWNERS, AND
ESPECIALLY TO PROTECT THE
VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY, THIS IS
THEIR DONOR BASE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE AND AGREE WITH YOU.
>> ONE LAST THING, WE ARE
TEACHING THE KIDS THAT WE DON'T
NEED MORE WOLVES.
WE DON'T NEED MORE SHEEP.
WE NEED MORE SHEEP.
THE WHOLE SHEEPDOG -- WE ARE